quand j'ai vu bokassa le sacre de
bokassa dans match j'ai eu le même
sentiment imagine à l'époque des
royalistes kouadio à l'époque de
napoléon qui voyait napoléon se faire
sacrer empereur dire que pour eux c'est
terrible parce que les mecs étaient
royal ici rue ney bourbon qui est sur le
trône depuis des siècles et d'un seul
coup voient arriver ce mec
ahmed 12 qui arrive de corse et qui
comptera se faire sacrer par le pape et
avec un apparat extraordinaire et en
fait on peut comprendre ce que ça a été
en regardant le sacre de bokassa à dire
que il s'est fait sacrer dans une
paisible décorum à celui mois alors
qu'elle était très était très fan de
napoléon déjà en fait je voulais aussi
raconter les gens ce qu'est ce que les
gens ne savent pas c'est que dans ma
famille on a une famille de notables
depuis des générations son propre père
était gouverneur de la centrafrique
oui tout à fait il est mort en janvier
avait cinq ans donc après la génèse de
ce bon score tout seul mais son arrière
grand oncle était le premier président
de la centrafrique est alors c'était
quoi ces diamants sérieusement vous qui
êtes nomme en fait l'histoire des
diamants c'est pas grand chose en fait
ce que s'est passé c'est que au sommet
les chefs d'état quand ils sont en
voyage diplomatique qui se font des
cadeaux d'état et un membre en perdre
considéré en afrique
en fait on va vous offrir ce qu'on
considère le plus beau dans le pays dont
mon grand-père qui représentait le plus
beau que son pays s'était légèrement
dont qui il a offert sa comme cadeau
d'état est normalement un cadeau d'état
on le met à l'élise
vous entendre au sens la paille je pense
qu'un ami ailleurs voilà assez simple
quand même personne a reproché à
egytiens d'avoir reçu des diamants de
bokassa c'est d'abord menti c'est le
mensonge qui tue tu peux pas dire c'est
que une histoire de diamants machin et
puis c'est parce qu'il a menti quand un
président d'une république est copain
avec un dictateur malades
complètement débile c'est la fin c'est
un côté que son mari filles de plus beau
au centrafrique s'ils avaient des plus
beaux centres fixes étaient quand même
la pauvreté du peuple il avait une
pauvreté nandina était la plus belle
je veux dire et surtout en france
non faut pas exagérer faut pas exagérer
c'était c'était un empereur d'opérette
complète d'autres étaient copains avec
juste parce qu'il allait chasser là bas
à la chasse et à l'amour avec ses grands
machins à rennes c'est dégoûtant faisait
absolument débutants et i'mhalal les
corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus